you see the batting average in the on
base percentage one in the same he
hasn't taken a walk yet again another
a lot of plate appearances up the middle
but there is
[Applause]
pretty pretty pretty stuff so much fun
asked him earlier this year we did a
post-game interview with him i said hey
do you are you familiar with pistol pete
maravich and he said no never heard of
him so you got to look him up because
that's what you remind me of
well that's a nice
mention a terrific basketball player
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and they're on their feet
as they should be
spectacular work by baez oh my goodness
wow
[Applause]
something early to howler about it
wrigley
oh yeah
[Music]
here we go with devon with a couple of
men on base
a tipping point in the third inning and
mills
gets the big rbi guy of the marlins
scoreless going to the bottom of the
third
the cubs two home run centric in their
last 12 including the hayward last 12
runs overall have come by way of homer
but you take anything you can get
on the 3-1 a walk base runners
david ross and this cubs team would like
get some base runners for somebody to
get up there with some power
[Applause]
towards short off of rojas
hayward to third peterson stops
hayward he's gonna oh he turned
the corner like he was coming home good
thing he went back
rojas made contact angel hernandez
indicating obstruction and hayward would
have been safe at third base regardless
of how this play shook out
all had a lot of pace on it and a safe
play brought to you by life or death
illinois it really is a matter of life
or death learn more at
lifeboat.illinois.com
cubs looking for a score here
it gets away and here comes hayward get
there safely for the cubs
in the home third
[Applause]
yeah
marlins
maybe trying to press the case that that
wasn't fouled off but i think it's just
a whiff on the part of alfaro yeah that
replay showed us jd
[Applause]
a head first stomach slide from the
alert hayward so the cubs
get a run here in the third with without
a hit hit a walk get an air he had some
hustle
one unearned run right now and three and
two thirds innings of work it was
hayward that walked and then scored on
the pass ball
[Applause]
throw down to second and rizzo's out
[Applause]
great throw by alfaro
terrific play alfaro and rojas combine
to pick off anthony rizzo two to six
for the third out and leave hayward at
the plate no runs no hits couple of
walks one was left on base
3-1 here want to
keep aguilar from doing damage
toward left center half says i got it
he does
and mills good through five shutting out
those
mighty marlins
the longer this goes on it feels like
the hitter is getting the advantage well
that's yeah that's uh yeah i think he
referenced a quote from jimmy leyland
who said that
and and and the
base percentage for sure and swings in
the favor of the hitter
the more pitches you see
towards short bible by rojas the throw
wisdom is on
rule the base hit nothing i think we can
give the crowd
some credit but wisdom
he had nine straight
foul balls
that one had some hair on a lot of
topspin took a nasty hop
ross talked about the energy with this
place his full 30 year old mariznick
first year with the cubs made his major
league debut with the marlins
in 2013 the center field
drops
two on
boy ross dialing the right matchups here
with the threat of reign
and gets through
winston rounds third
he's going to score mariznick to third
and say
it's two nothing tops
delivers a big rbi single here
but way up above the belt 92 mile an
hour fast off the top of the zone he's
able to get on top of it and hitting
sharply through that hole on the right
side as you see from our t mobile
coverage cam good throw to third
mariznick with his speed able to get in
there just ahead of this throw from
duvall
working around rbi then aguilar and
duval
struck him out
nice work by ryan tupara
on eight pitches he takes care of the
marlins and we're going to the bottom of
the sixth
have not had a runner get to third today
that's how good that pitching has been
for the cubs
very struck about
just like
[Applause]
you that one of the top strikeout
artists of all time you know he'd love
to finish with a punch out
happy father's day cubs win
and that's how it goes with kimbrough
closing
two nothing comes the last three wins
have come
by that exact score of two nothing
come stay in first place in the central
25 and 12 at home their 40th win of the
season